has value and runs around sleeping a lot
of women could he be a hoe no why
because again right attraction is a very
subjective term and women don't
typically look at a man's physical
appearance to determine traction they
typically look at behavior and like
communication style fine but if he
sleeps sleep a lot of women and if we're
putting women in the same context if she
sleeps with a lot of men she's a hoe If
a man sleeps with a lot of women
regardless of who he is you know how
attractive is value whatever if he's
sleeping with another woman wouldn't he
be a hoe you're applying the exact same
parameters but withdrawing well he can't
a man can't get pregnant right and so
there's no negative consequence to him
sleeping a lot of women
I mean STDs but also why is that the
application here is is that a woman who
sleeps with a lot of men right that's
that's because because that's easy to do
so it's like it's easy for a woman to
sleep with a lot of guys go outside and
say does anyone want to have sex with me
you can get it done if a dude does that
they look at him like he's nuts
you know what changed my like
perspective on this is I went to a
pickup artist boot camp once this is the
wildest thing I've ever seen like these
guys paid thousands of dollars to learn
how to get laid Yeah thousands of
dollars and literally like went through
coaching like trying to figure out how
to build attraction with a girl like all
this stuff and I'm just like all I all I
have to do is exist so if you bring that
back too you have a vagina but if we
bring that back to what we're talking
about in terms of virginity when we were
younger in terms of like girls weren't
really thinking about it that much and
kind of saw it as this Victory right
isn't that what we're taught but that's
what's pushed onto us that men losing
their virginity and sleeping with lots
of women is like this you know like high
achievement so they pay lots of money
because if you get laid a lot then
you're seen as you know successful right
yeah I would say it is a high
achievement because historically most
men didn't even reproduce only 40 of men
reproduce historically where 80 of women
did and even up 8 000 years ago 17 women
reproduced for every one man and so it's
it's like that's an achievement most men
don't even get to reproduce and I know
like now you know you take away the
reproduction because we have birth
control but you don't get rid of biology
so are we reducing it to reproduction
then so when that was the initial reason
we've definitely developed as a society
right past that point where it's not
just about reproduction but I'm saying
like you can't get rid of the way people
feel
in terms of like men are naturally
predisposition to be repulsed by a girl
that sleeps around and so I'm just like
the same way you typically women like
men that are taller than us and men
don't come to us and say oh you
shouldn't like men taller than us like
no so I would say again that that would
like there's some angry little men out
there
I
in terms of like evolving over time
right biologically evolving over time
I'd say that there's other attitudes
that have also evolved over time kind of
and that are probably taking up more
space now maybe haven't got to the same
point as that same mindset but I do
think we can get to a point where that
can shift right especially because it's
evolved it's a mindsets evolved based on
what we've been taught we can be taught
different things and change that
gradually but we have to be open to that
so I I agree with you I do think it's
evolved over time where like typically
before as I said like I would say men
are more forgiving with body count than
they used to be so I would agree with
you that it has evolved but is it better
like are the outcomes better nowadays is
that any space that kind of promotes
like I said acceptance and understanding
of why we behave in certain ways and why
we drift towards certain things and and
understanding how it can harm because I
feel like that kind of mindset of like
um in terms of you know if you slept a
lot of people as like woman as a man
you're successful is is essentially
harmful
um because it places a lot of that
emphasis on on that um
but the thing is it's true and I just
think like you can live in delusion it's
true right now and I would agree with
that yes 100 I would say that that is if
we talk about like the general that is
kind of the general mindset at the
moment I would agree but does that mean
it's the best mindset right and and who
are you to determine what's the best
mindset yeah because I'm trying to
understand that he you said it's harmful
harmful to who like so so in terms of
like situations like grape right men who
or like in cells right who who don't
maybe have that same achievement right
they they kind of resort to quite
violent means in order to reach that
same level success or they feel kind of
like you know put out because they don't
get to be able to do it and that's why
in cell culture kind of develops because
they think like a certain group of men
only gets all the women because you know
they're this high level and then and
then often they turn violent right and
it can be a very destructive view when
you place all the emphasis on that like
Macho not Macho which are probably not
the right word to say there
um that like hyper masculine focus on on
sexuality and seeing it as something to
achieve right when we do that and then
men don't and then they don't feel
masculine anymore and they feel
emasculated by it and that can turn very
violent so it can be dangerous for
society and I'm not saying this is me
you know saying oh this is I'm saying
it's a point to consider it's a thing to
talk about when we're considering what's
best forever you're actually somewhat
correct it is dangerous for society what
like the more um like the when there's a
large group of men that aren't getting
laid basically that is dangerous versus
you know what happens when men don't get
laid but it's because the emphasis is on
the fact you know and that's where we've
put so it becomes more aggressive
no males yeah exactly they become more
aggressive when they don't but I think
that's because of the emphasis that we
put on being late and essentially from
biology survival reproduction yeah it's
not an emphasis it's a biological thing
but it's it's we are taught that we are
taught that through biology that is
something that is evolved based on what
we've been taught and through a need for
survival right to reproduce to be able
to you know reproduce your bloodline in
lineage and that sort of thing it's a
survival
you don't know what it is there are
other ways to release you don't have to
release you're a woman I'm a man men
need to release their testosterone they
need to have testosterone hang on hang
on they need to find a way in which they
need to release how do you release how
do you release but by shagging some
shagging some birds is that how you
release is that is that your release is
that sorry you just said you just said
wait wait yeah I hate you but what I'm
saying to you is men are biologically
wired a certain way okay are you a
biologist
men are biologically wired a certain way
okay okay so so what happens in society
is that when men are not getting
sexual when men are not sexually um also
what I'm looking for gratified gratified
gratified yes that's the word but men
are not sexually gratified they get more
aggressive do they so okay sorry sorry
when they are more sexually gratified
they're less violent
okay that is the biggest logical fallacy
I've ever heard in mind
it's not a logical fallacy it is it's
true
thank you I'd have to agree you're right
okay so so we've got three minutes
saying it's true so you explain why it's
a logical fallacy so you're saying that
if I don't get laid I am gonna hit
someone I said you explain why it's a
logical fallacy well you said you've
never had trouble talking to women so
you probably wouldn't know what that's
like right like you said earlier in the
show you've never had trouble talking to
women you're good with the ladies yeah
so you guys should really ask Joseph
about this yeah you should really asked
Justin about this he has a lot of study
in history and like knowledge on the go
and Justin well so I mean it's Evolution
psychology but more also than that like
I mean if a man masturbates he can get
it really so you won't feel as
aggressive right but if I mean I don't
know if you guys ever heard of nofap I'm
a huge advocate for the no fat movement
and uh like seven years into it right
and I know if I don't have sex for like
I don't know a week or two I start
feeling extremely aggressive right and I
think it's very common for for men to
feel that way because when you abstain
from sex your testosterone is increasing
you need to have that release and if you
don't believe me go try it go stop
jerking off stop having sex for two
weeks three weeks and see how you feel
but would you not agree with those other
ways to release other than just sexual
you're a woman
yeah no I realize that I'm talking to
men thank you but I I can enter into the
conversation yeah I don't think about it
right and I'm saying are there not other
ways for you to release not just sex
through exercise right through physical
engagement and and healthy and in a
controlled environment right it's not
the same as busting or not
fair enough thank you Jeff thank you for
being so like so Justin you're gonna be
so honest you're like you're you're club
promoter YouTuber yep yes yes so like
your your work Outlet is
having conversations like this yeah and
busting a nut yeah yeah sure yeah sweet
so how how do you how do you manage your
aggression you say you're seven years
into this nofap how do you manage your
question when you feel it coming up fair
enough as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible